Stromboli is not happy with the tangled
mass,
but then the crowd reacts very
positively and then that confuses the
conscience because he thinks,
well look,
this is horrible.
This guy's a tyrant like Pinocchio,
making a fool of himself.
Everything turns into a tangled mess,
but the crowd goes crazy and well,
the inner fool,
that can be entertaining,
right?
So it's hard to tell when the crowd,
especially out of spectacle,
because that's this crowd is at a
spectacle.
You just don't know exactly why it is
that they're responding positively,
but you definitely give them what you
want and you can see this look on
strombolis face.
It's like this false.
Again,
this false kindness and generosity,
public facing and oh well.
Anyways,
the conscience is very confused and I
really think this is an important thing
because I've often thought I spent a lot
of time thinking about Hitler and I was
thinking,
well,
how do you get into a state like that?
You know,
and you think,
well,
he's a dictator and he led his people
down a bad path.
It's like,
that's not right.
That is not what happened.
They had a conspiracy together and went
down a bad path.
Now think about it this way.
If one person thinks something about
you,
it's like whatever,
right?
But if five people tell you that,
well,
what?
Then then to start to start not taking
that seriously.
It's kind of narcissistic.
Right?
And if it isn't five,
let's say it's 15 people tell you the
same thing or act the same way towards
you.
It's like probably you should clue in,
well what if you're a politician and
you're trying out a bunch of different
ideas and you're good at interacting
with the crowd,
you're charismatic,
you watch the crowd,
but you're not necessarily all that
articulate.
You don't have your values all straight
now,
but you're kind of angry too,
and maybe that's because you spent a
bunch of time in World War One,
world war one in the trenches,
which was like no joke and all your
friends got blown up you and then you
were unemployed and then you tried to be
an artist and that didn't work out even
though you were moderately talented and
then maybe the economy fell apart
completely on you.
Hyperinflation and then maybe there was
a communist menace coming in from the
east and they're genuinely was and so
you're not the world's happiest clam at
that point and you're talking to people
who aren't that happy either because
they were also badly defeated in world
war one and then they had a terrible
treaty.
They had decided they lost part of their
territory and so the crowd's not happy
and neither are you and there's reason
for it,
and so you start talking to them.
You don't know what you're upset about
and neither does the crowd,
so you start to articulate some things
about why you might be upset and some of
them fall flat,
but you're paying attention to the
crowd,
so you stopped saying those things and
some of the things make the crowd really
wake up and listen,
and so you start seeing more of those
things.
Right?
It's an.
It's an unconscious dialectic between
you and the crowd.
It's mediated by consciousness,
but it's not like you're sitting there
saying,
although you might be,
I'm going to this crowd more what it
wants to hear.
It's more sophisticated than that,
and so you do that thousand times and
you do that to ever increasing crowds
and the crowd really starts to go mad
and they basically tell you that you're
the savior of the nation.
It's like at what?
How many bloody people have to tell you
that before you start to believe it,
you know?
I would say with a typical person,
100,
we'll do it now.
That'll get you going,
man.
If 100 people tell you specifically why
you're special,
you're going to be thinking.
Even if you're kind of humbled to begin
with,
you're going to be thinking,
Geez,
there's got to be something to this man,
but if it's a million people and they're
roaring their approval.
Well,
and then when it's a whole nation,
it's like good luck withstanding that.
There's just not a chance.
How are you going to withstand that?
Now you could be like Gandhi and you
could have taken that into account
beforehand because he did he read
tolstoy by the way,
he was a student of tolstoy and that's.
It's very interesting because tolstoy
was the person who developed the
techniques of nonviolence that gone to
USD and tolstoy was also a deeply
religious writer apart from his novels,
which are not,
I wouldn't say really in the religious
category,
although they're profound,
um,
tolstoy stressed humility with
nonviolence.
He really stressed that and that's what
Gandhi took to heart.
So he lived a very,
very,
very simple bare bones,
ascetic life.
And that was to kind of see if he could
keep his damn ego tamp down.
Well,
the groundswell was building behind him,
you know,
when he dressed really simply and he
didn't own much and he ate very simply
and he just tried to stay away from the
whole materialistic success element that
would be an element of what would turn
them into an actor and also inflate his
ego.
And you know,
he seemed to do that pretty well.
You know,
he certainly.
Well,
he led a nonviolent revolution that
resulted in the,
in the independence of India.
It also produced a terrible civil war
and the separate separation of the
Muslim Indians from the Hindu Indians.
And,
but I don't think you can precisely laid
out at the feet of Gandhi,
right?
But,
but what I'm saying is that you have to
be an extraordinary person.
You have to be extraordinarily wise and
you have to take ridiculous precautions
if you're going to put yourself in the
public sphere like that and expose
yourself to that kind of adulation
without becoming a puppet of the crowd.
And that's what happened to Hitler.
I mean it's not like he wasn't also a
conscious manipulator and surrounded
himself by people who are propagandists
and all of that.
So there was a conscious element,
but you got to think these things
through and see how that dialectic
develops.
Like he learned how to appeal to the
darkest fantasies of the crowd.
He was really,
really good at it and that was a
dialectic process,
right?
The crowd told them what they wanted to
hear and it's the crowds a mob at that
point.
So I don't have to take responsibility.
The fact that I'm screaming my approval
when I'm surrounded by a million people
so I can scream my approval for whatever
I want forever.
Whatever dark revengeful fantasy might
be playing out in my imagination because
I'm not going to be held accountable for
it.